more people have officially died of
kovid on joe biden's watch than did on
donald trump's watch which creates a
problem for joe biden because last year
biden claimed that any president with as
many covid deaths as trump on his watch
has no right to be the president of the
united states
here is jensaki twisting herself into
logical illogical pretzels to defend her
party's incoherent view of death
in 2020 when roughly 220 000 americans
had already died of covet joe biden said
about trump anyone who is responsible
for that many deaths should not remain
as president of the united states of
america is that still the standard now
that more americans have died under
president biden than president trump i
think the fundamental question here is
what are you doing to save lives and
protect people and the former president
was suggesting people inject bleach he
apparently reportedly didn't even share
with people he was going to interact
with that he had tested positive for
kovit himself he continued to provide a
forum for misinformation which probably
led to people not getting uh not taking
steps forward to get to protect
themselves to wear a mask to eventually
get vaccinated this president has made
the vaccine widely available he's relied
on the health the advice of his health
and medical experts and he is trying to
be a part of solving this crisis getting
the pandemic under control and i think
there's a pretty stark difference
between their approaches
so she lied donald trump never told
anyone to inject themselves with bleach
whatever you think about the vaccine
donald trump is largely responsible for
getting that vaccine out in time a
timetable that joe biden and chris
wallace and everybody in the
establishment said could not happen
trump said it is going to happen it did
happen but jensachi
also avoided the issue
she never addressed
the question that she was asked she
never addressed biden's argument about
trump and she tried to move the goal
posts on life death and legitimacy which
coincidentally is exactly what the left
has been doing on the issue of abortion
for the better part of 50 years since
the supreme court's decision in roe vs
wade
which coincidentally may very well be on
the brink of being overruled after oral
arguments concluded yesterday and
potentially the most consequential
supreme court case of our lifetimes i'm
michael knowles the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday by far it was from
mikey79 who said now that cuomo got
cancelled from cnn the daily wire should
hire him like they do with everyone that
gets cancelled by the media yes i agree
i agree it would i was thinking
is it worth hiring a cancelled cnn host
just for the laws
and i thought i don't know it seems kind
of
un self-undermining but no i think for
the laws it would be 100 worth i can't
wait for the chris cuomo show brought to
you by the daily wire i can't wait to
have fredo on backstage just so that we
can kick him around that'd be a lot of
fun it would make me feel very verily if
you want to feel very virile i would
recommend you check out
roman whether you've been married for
years or are just getting started having
the confidence that comes from
preparation means that you are free to
enjoy the moment when the moment comes
go to getroman.com
knowles k-w-l-e-s to speak to a u.s
licensed health care professional about
erectile dysfunction and get 15 off your
first month of treatment
the benefits of ed treatment can help
you reconnect with your loved one and
rediscover the joy of that thing that is
very fun to do roman ready is confidence
personified it is the self-assurance
that comes from knowing you've prepared
yourself for the moment when intimacy
arrives roman's system is completely
confidential totally discreet no big
logos or labels on packages i know this
is the sort of thing that men don't want
to talk about well you don't really have
to talk about it too much you can you
can get your online evaluation and get
ongoing care for e.d from the comfort
and privacy of your own home go to get
roman dot com slash knowles canadawlis
if you're prescribed get 15 off your
first month of ed treatment make sure
you are ready to have confidence and
control
roman ready the oral arguments yesterday
in the dobbs versus jackson women's
health
case were incredible
they went on for two hours very few
people listened to the whole thing
though it actually
was
incredibly engrossing
mostly for the
failures of the pro-abortion side and
the pro-abortion justices to make their
case
i listened to every minute of it i've
got the highlights for you here is it
actually started with the pro-life side
making their arguments and the more
conservative judges asking questions but
i want to start with the pro-abortion
side just
to demonstrate
what a thin argument they made
mr chief justice and may it please the
court
mississippi's ban on abortion two months
before viability is flatly
unconstitutional under decades of
precedent
mississippi asks the court to dismantle
this precedent and allow states to force
women to remain pregnant and give birth
against their will
the court should refuse to do so for at
least three reasons
first stery decisis presents an
especially high bar here
in casey this court carefully examined
and rejected every possible reason for
overruling roe
holding that a woman's right to end a
pregnancy before viability was a rule of
law and a component of liberty it could
not renounce
the question then is not whether rose
should be overturned but whether casey
was egregiously wrong to adhere to rose
central holding
second casey and roe were correct
for a state to take control of a woman's
body and demand that she go through
pregnancy and childbirth with all the
physical risks and life-altering
consequences that brings is a
fundamental deprivation of her liberty
third
eliminating or reducing the right to
abortion will propel women backwards
okay it goes on and it gets even vaguer
and and less grounded to reality did you
notice what was missing in her opening
argument
the
constitution the law itself
she focuses
on two things she focuses on precedent
and story decisis which is just a fancy
term for precedent
and she focuses on liberty in the
abstract
but what about
the constitution what about the laws
where is the so-called right to abortion
where is it in the constitution you're
saying that this new law in mississippi
this pro-life law is unconstitutional
show me where is it she can't she keeps
going back to precedent
the precedence being roe versus wade and
then planned parenthood v casey which
kind of affirmed roe versus wade but
actually kind of changed the reasoning
it came to the same conclusion which is
that there's this
mythical right to abortion in the
constitution but it kind of used
different reasoning for it so she goes
back to those decisions but she has to
rely on story decisis and precedent
because the decisions were obviously
wrong
the decisions were not based in the
constitution and so she can't point to
the constitution and say here's your
right to abortion she has to point to
the precedent but there have been plenty
of bad decisions in the history of the
united states
dred scott
right
decisions that would that said that uh
black people could never be citizens
this uh plenty of other a lot of
decisions regarding civil rights were
bad decisions so in that case would you
point to precedent and say well it's
precedent so black people can never be
citizens because it's precedent it's
starting decisis what do you want to
overturn our whole system no so
extremely weak arguments and then she
makes this argument from lit and it's
liberty well what show me the liberty
show me the actual laws show me the
actual rights and then that final
argument you heard her make sure you
goes it'll send women backward oh wow
really impressive legal argument lady
it's not if we don't do this if if we if
we overrule roe versus wait it'll be not
very progressive uh okay well
whoopty do who cares make an argument
from the law she can't do it and justice
clarence thomas
probably the most conservative judge on
the court one of the most conservative
judges on the court the and the
longest-standing member there
he hit her on this point he said hey
lady can you bring it back from all this
generality and actually come back down
to earth
what i'm trying to focus on
is if we
is to lower the level of generality or
at least be a little bit more specific
in the old days we used to say it was a
right to privacy that the court found in
the
due process substantive due process
clause okay
so or in substantive due process and i'm
trying to get you to tell me what are we
relying on now is it privacy is it
autonomy what is it i think it continues
to be liberty and the right exists
whatever level of generality the court
applies yeah i think it's like freedom
man you know hold excuse me mr jess just
one second
yeah man it's just kind of like you know
liberty you know and so she refuses to
do what justice thomas asks her to do
namely
cite some provision of the constitution
to justify her legal claims and
i guess
even more incredibly as bad as the
performance was from the pro-abortion
lawyer
the pro-abortion judges
were possibly worse i'm thinking in
particular of sonia sotomayor
who
le was less asking questions than making
an argument herself and it wasn't a very
good one
probably her strongest argument
was to compare babies in the womb
to brain dead people
virtually every state defines
a brain death as death
yet the literature is filled with
episodes of people who are completely
and elderly injured
responding to stimuli
there's about 40 percent of dead people
who if you touch their feet
the foot will recoil
there are spontaneous acts by dead brain
people
so i don't think
that a response
to
uh by a fetus necessarily proves
that there's a sensation of pain
or that there's consciousness
sonia sotomayor calling anybody brain
dead is the clearest example of a pot
and kettle that i've ever seen from the
supreme court when i was in college i
saw sonia sotomayor give a lecture
and
my only comment on it i don't even
remember what the lecture was about was
that i and many other people who were in
that room left left the room thinking
huh
not the brightest bulb in the pack that
one and she has a reputation for being
the dumbest judge on the court and she
is the dumbest judge on the court
the point she's making just isn't even
true by the way if you are brain dead
you're not getting better
you are only being kept alive
or even appearing to be kept alive by
machines
if you are a baby in the womb
you are
growing you are going you're going to
become more and more conscious you're
going to become more and more sentient
more and more aware
the the analogy
is
not only imprecise it's absurd
and
and it shows a ghastly view from the
left of babies
that they that they
think that they're
dead it's it's unscientific
it's immoral
and uh it's
not fit for the supreme court
now when you want to protect your
country and your way of life
i think you got to start at the dinner
table which is why i was i would suggest
checking out good ranchers did you know
that in just the last six years over 100
000 farms and ranches in the united
states have shut down and you know why
because foreigners are stealing their
stuff and their market position
foreign meat is stealing their business
and robbing you of the quality and
flavor that you deserve that's why good
ranchers is here a lot of the meat that
you'll see in the grocery store that has
a kind of usa type label on it is
actually not
from america it's actually from other
other countries and then it's processed
here don't do that the good ranchers
have gone out they have found great
american ranches really exceptional
quality beef better than organic chicken
really top quality stuff i love the
burgers myself to me the burgers are
absolutely out of this world go to
goodranchers.com knowles canada wlas
right now get 10 free bistro fillets in
addition if you subscribe you will save
25 bucks off each subscription box of
mouth-watering american meats for life
these boxes will show up on schedule
right to your door that is 10 free
bistro fillets that's a 119 value free
express shipping and 25 off your monthly
subscription for life at
goodranchers.com knowles
goodranchers.com knowles or use code
knowles at checkout 10 free bistro
filets free spread shipping 25 bucks off
your monthly subscription for life
goodranchers.com
knowles sonia sotomayor then moves on
from her silly brain dead argument reign
dead in all sense of that term to
make a political argument she says if
the supreme court overrules roe versus
wade and planned parenthood v casey how
will it survive the politicization
will this institution
survive the
stench that this creates
in the public perception
that the constitution
and its reading
are just political
acts i i i don't see how it is possible
it's what
casey talked about when it talked about
watershed decisions
some of them brown versus board of
education it mentioned
and this one
have
such
an entrenched
set of expectations in our society that
this is what the court decided this is
what we will follow
that the that we won't be able to
survive
if people believe that everything
including new york versus sullivan
i could name any other set of rights
actually the opposite view seems to be
correct
every time the court has has tried to
base its decision on what it thinks will
protect it from accusations of
politicization it appears more
politicized this is one of the biggest
problems with chief justice roberts
roberts
is so concerned with protecting the
institutional integrity of the court
that he often seems to be ruling against
his own judgment the clearest example of
this was obamacare but other decisions
as well
and ironically what that does is makes
us
view the court in a more partisan and
political way because the judges are not
acting on principle or constitutional
text they're acting to try to manage the
passions of the people
so that objection from sotomayor i think
is totally bogus
then she moves on to what was lying
underneath a lot of these arguments
which is their antipathy to
christianity and religion
how is your interest anything but
a religious view
the issue of when life begins
has been hotly debated by philosophers
since the beginning of time
it's still debated in religions
so when you say this is the only right
that takes away from the state
the ability to protect the life
that's a religious view isn't it
because it assumes
that a fetus is life
at
when
you're not drawing you're when do you
suggest we begin that way
your honor i i
aside from putting it aside from
religion
i i i'll try to i think there might be
more than one question and i'll do my
very best justice sotomayor um i think
this court and gonzalez pretty clearly
recognized that before viability we are
talking with unborn life with a human
organism and i think the philosophical
questions your honor mentioned all those
reasons that they're hard they've been
debated they're they're they're
important those are all reasons to
return this to the people because the
people should get to debate these hard
issues
how is your view anything different than
a religious view i'm almost doing a
fouchy for sotomayor here i guess
they're bothered both from new york
well i guess it is kind of a religious
view but so is your view your honor
if the question is when does life begin
now just from a purely scientific view
we know life begins at conception all
the qualities that we would describe as
being involved in life are there from
the very moment of conception
but if sonia sotomayor is making some
higher argument that you're not really
alive until you speak until you're
conscious until you feel pain until
which creates all these bioethical
questions what if someone's in a coma
are they no longer alive can you just
kill them probably not
but
even beyond that scientific ignorance
is the and the philosophical and
religious ignorance is even the
ignorance of the role of religion
what sonia sotomayor is saying is that
my religious view this sort of
materialist feminist leftist religious
view that is
totally kosher completely protected by
our political tradition but your
religious view
that human life has worth and we should
protect it that is totally outside the
purview of the constitution how dare you
force your religion on me
but it's all religious you know we say
politics is downstream of culture well
culture's downstream of religion cult
and culture come from the same root word
so obviously these when we talk about
the morality of killing people we're
talking about religion when we talk
about the morality of taxes we're
talking about religion okay you can't
escape that and what these lib justices
are blinded to
is their own religious views which they
consider to be common sense and and
totally accepted by everybody and
they'll they're willing to punish you if
you don't accept their their kooky
religious views justice breyer did the
same thing religion kept popping up
justice breyer is a slightly more
intelligent lib lawyer on the court
and and he kept asking the pro-life side
well hold on i want you to cite secular
people i want you to cite atheists
in your argument
are there secular philosophers and
bioethicists
who take the position
that
the rights of personhood
begin um at conception or at some point
other than viability
um i i believe so i mean i think there's
a wide array i mean of of of people of
kind of all different views and and of
no faith views who would reasonably have
that view your honor it's it's not tied
to a religious view and i don't think
word otherwise this court's
jurisprudence would on this issue would
run right into some of its uh religious
exercise jurisprudence so the pro-life
lawyer there does a good job of
remaining measured and respectful but i
think the real answer to this question
is who cares who cares what some secular
liberal atheist philosopher thinks those
people are idiots they're wrong it's
it's like saying
excuse me um council can you cite a
radical leftist
who agrees with your view no i can't
because i'm a conservative and the
leftist is wrong
hey um
uh council can you cite someone who is
wrong about the fundamental question the
the basic nature of reality can you cite
someone who's completely wrong about
that to to back up your argument uh no i
can't because i try not to
base my arguments on the thoughts of
dummies
by the way by the way this country this
guy america which i know we're supposed
to say is super secular and separation
of church and state or whatever
america is based on the idea
that there are certain unalienable
rights that we are endowed with by our
creator who exists and those rights are
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
if that creator whose name is god
does not exist then the premise of the
country
doesn't make any
sense so far from being a secular
atheist country like these
silly people want us to believe we are
not the country is based on religion and
specifically it's premised on
christianity so so justice thomas
thankfully justice thomas comes in and
he tries to bring this back down to
reality he says hold on wait aren't
we we're talking about abortion right is
that can we can we get back to the the
thing about abortion please
general would you
specifically tell me uh
specifically uh
state what the right is is it
specifically abortion
is it uh liberty is it autonomy is it
privacy
the right is grounded in the liberty
component of the 14th amendment justice
thomas but i think that it promotes
interest in autonomy bodily integrity
liberty and equality and i do think that
it is specifically the right to abortion
here the right of a woman to be able to
control without the state forcing her to
continue a pregnancy whether to carry
that baby to term
the state isn't forcing the woman into a
pregnancy
the state isn't forcing the woman to
become a mother the woman already became
a mother at the moment of conception
the question is does the state have the
right to make laws against killing the
baby who already exists and of course
the state has the right to do that of
course we the people have the right to
do that we have plenty of laws against
murder and assault and all sorts of laws
and we absolutely have the right to do
that thomas pr he tries one more time
and then he gives up he says can you
plea i can identify
the second amendment the fourth
amendment but i can't what right are you
talking about what is confusing is
that we if we were talking about the
second amendment i know exactly what
we're talking about if we're talking
about fourth amendment i know what we're
talking about
because it's written it's there
what specifically is the right here
that we're talking about
well justice thomas i think that the
court in those other contexts with
respect to those other amendments has
had to articulate what the text means
and the bounds of the constitutional
guarantees and it's done so through a
variety of different tests that
implement first amendment rights second
amendment rights fourth amendment rights
so i don't think that there is anything
unprecedented or anomalous about the
right that the court articulated in
rowan casey and the way that it
implemented that right by defining the
scope of the liberty interest by
reference to viability and providing
that that is the moment when the balance
of interest tips and when the state can
act to prohibit a woman from from
getting an abortion based on its
interest in protecting the fetal life at
that point so the right specifically is
abortion
it's the right of a woman prior to
viability to control whether to continue
with a pregnancy yes
so justice thomas says can you cite the
right it's abortion right can you cite
it where is it and her answer is no i'll
translate all that legal
jump jargon try to dance around it no
she can't they had no argument now does
this mean roe will be overruled i'm
cautiously optimistic but just on the
performance of the lawyers and the
judges for that matter
the pro-life side made the best case
that they could have and it's an
extremely strong case the pro-abortion
side
absolutely collapsed
now when you want to protect your own
health not just the health of other
people but your own health i would
strongly recommend you check out echelon
i love my echelon you know that i am not
exactly a gym rat okay i don't i just
don't have the time all right that's my
main excuse for why i don't go to the
gym because you know you go you got to
change you got to drive what 25 minutes
to the gym you got to get out you get on
the thing or whatever you shower that's
another however long 10 minutes then you
got to change and you got to drive it's
too much with echelon you can bring the
gym home
when you're trying to reach your fitness
goals it can really help to have
world-class instructors choreographing
classes music from your favorite artists
and a community of hundreds of thousands
of people who can give you that extra
push
they've got all this incredible workout
equipment i've got the bike the bike is
amazing with a nice big screen where i
can participate in in live classes and
on-demand classes great music it's
terrific it's the only thing that can
get me to work at and it's a lot of fun
and you can do it in 20 minutes
15 minutes or an hour they've got all
this great stuff
at the auto folding treadmill they've
got i love the bike myself
right now for a limited time podcast
listeners can get up to 800 off msrp
to get this exclusive discount text
knowles k wles to 81 81 81
that is knowles canada wles text it to
81 8181 get up to 800 bucks off msrp
text knolls to 818181 message and data
rates may apply c terms for details also
head on over to get johnny the walrus
this is the beloved children's author
matt walsh's new book
johnnythewallrisk.com
that's where you can go to reserve your
copy of maths timely masterpiece johnny
the walrus today also stay tuned at the
end of the show we will have a trailer
for daley wire's new movie shut in we
will be playing it for you i will be
reacting i haven't seen the trailer
before it just came out as we were here
doing the show so stay tuned for that
we'll be right back with a lot more
you know moving on from the supreme
court we're going to hear more about
this case obviously in the months to
come
but
beyond that just to the the issue there
is one objection that i have heard from
even otherwise kind of conservative
people on this issue of abortion and it
actually does get to the heart of it it
gets to the heart of the whole abortion
debate and it's not even about the life
of the baby and it's not even about
competing rights between the baby and
the mother
it gets to this question of men and
women and they will say well
it's not fair it's not fair that if a
man and a woman do that thing that they
probably shouldn't be doing unless
they're married if you know if they
head on up to lover's point you know and
they do that thing and then
the woman gets pregnant
the man can just walk away and the woman
has this baby and that's not fair
how's that fair how are we gonna
tolerate that why is it
that the man can just walk away and the
woman can't
because men and women are different
that's why that's why
and i
sympathize with you i empathize with you
that this
culture of feminism and liberalism and
progressivism
has persuaded you that men and women are
exactly the same and their approach to
sex should be exactly the same and their
approach to the the professional world
should be exactly the same and their
approach to family should be exactly the
same but it's not if that's just a lie
it's just dumb and wrong and dishonest
and false
men and women are different and so
when the men and women's experience of
the world is going to be a bit different
and certainly men and women's experience
of sex and pregnancy is going to be
different and i'm sorry that you were
lied to by feminists and leftists and
secularists and all the rest of them
but it's just the case
and so what the left has tried to do
to hide the difference between men and
women is give women this special right
to kill their babies because they think
if if women have the right to kill their
babies then they can at least kind of
pretend
that their experience of sex and
pregnancy will be the same right because
you
you won't necessarily have to raise this
kid or even deal with the question of
giving the baby up for adoption there
are plenty of parents who want to adopt
babies many more parents who want to
adopt than babies up for adoption but
you won't even have to deal with that
because if you could you can just go to
this doctor in the secret little room
and the doctor will kill your kid and
then it'll be just like you're a man
you can just walk away now there can be
laws
to protect women here
right
and no fault divorce that would protect
women
make men men already have to pay a lot
of child support but toughen up the
child support laws sure
you can you can pass laws to make this a
little better
but
the
the central fantasy here is that men and
women are exactly the same
and the grave crime and sin that has
been used to
defend this fantasy that men and women
are exactly the same and to and to
bolster that appearance is this special
right for women to kill their babies
that is a hideous crime and
the fantasy is wrong too and when
society lives according to fantasy
things don't turn out very well speaking
of which there's a tick talk
that's gone viral from our friends over
at libs of tick tock one of the great
twitter accounts
of a
transgender satanist explaining
and he's got he's got all these facial
tattoos and lots of crazy piercings and
looks
it would seem intentionally very scary
he's obviously got a lot of problems and
he's explaining
the philosophical center of his
strange appearance
i'm just going to post this every time
people ask me the same questions over
and over again my name is farah i am a
trans woman as well as an intersex woman
my pronouns are she her they them or
your grace
my eyes are tattooed
my nose is a piercing
i identify as a threat a nightmare and a
goddess so please bow down to me i do
not believe in god i don't worship the
devil but yes i am a satanist which
means i am my own god and i worship
myself
thank you have a good day
so a lot of people are looking at this
and saying man
there's a lot of untreated mental
illness out there and i bet this person
has some psychological problems
but the person also has spiritual and
philosophical problems and today because
our our country operates in this very
materialist way
where we deny spiritual reality and it
makes us go kind of schizophrenic
because on the one hand we say there's
no such thing as the solar spirit we're
just meat puppets and
you know we're just bags of chemicals
but then on the other hand we say our
bodies don't mean anything and if we
think if i'm a man and i think i'm a
woman then i actually am a woman and the
physical world the flesh means nothing
and the spirit means everything and
we've got this really schizophrenic view
rather than the reality of the situation
which is that we're body and soul
combined right body and spirit together
so
the more interesting thing that this
person says is
beyond the eye tattoos and the face
tattoos and the giant piercing through
his nose and all that he says i am a
satanist
but i don't believe in god and i don't
worship satan i worship myself
and i am a god and i'm a goddess
like as though this is some clever thing
you'll hear this from certain satanist
groups they say oh you we're just we're
using the word satanism kind of
ironically you don't we don't really
believe in gods and deities and devils
we just worship ourselves
as if that isn't what satanism always
was that that is satanism that's what
satan did that's what made satan fall
like lightning from heaven it was satan
an angel
chose to worship himself and pursue his
own will rather than the will of god
this is just
straight out of the bible and then he
falls from heaven
and and goes down to hell this is what
john milton writes about in paradise
lost he says the mind is satan is saying
this when he's cast down into hell he
says the mind is its own place and can
make a heaven of hell and uh hell of
heaven
but but that isn't true you actually
can't do that and the more that the
satan in milton's paradise lost thinks
that way the the worse off he becomes
and eventually becomes a snake and he
and anywhere he turns he's stuck
in hell as are these people
if you pursue your own
will
divorced from the moral order
if you pursue your own disordered
desires divorced from good
and if you pursue your own fantasies
divorced from reality
you are going to end up in hell
in the afterlife and in this life too
and in your personal life and in society
too
and that person in the who has all those
problems on tick tock
that person would seem to be living in a
kind of hell
and maybe we all focus on the chemical
reasons for that maybe this person needs
to take this drug or that drug or this
antidepressant or whatever but there's a
spiritual and philosophical issue here
too
and the same thing goes for our public
life the same thing goes for abortion
okay and and a lot of other political
issues but abortion's a pretty clear one
because it involves a mother killing her
own child
you you can't you can't escape it you
can't escape moral reality you can't you
can try
and a lot of people try even on the
right you know the left certainly tries
even on the right the kind of more
libertarian point of view is that we can
escape the moral order we don't need to
be beholden to any moral order it's just
our willfulness our choice our desires
that's all that really matters but it's
not it's not
and the men who developed our country
knew that
and great statesmen throughout history
have known that and we
stupidly have forgotten that and the
more we forget it the crappier our
country looks
and it's as simple as that
speaking
of living in an increasingly decayed and
scary looking
civilization
there's a news report just came out of
australia
that some some fugitives were on the
loose
these fugitives did not commit
murder
theft arson
these days if you commit those crimes
you'll actually be celebrated as long as
you're a member of blm and antifa no
these men
they are fugitives not from
justice
but from
a covid
quarantine camp
we've been told the trio scaled the
fence in the early hours of this morning
police receiving reports around 4 40 a.m
now major police checkpoints have been
set up around howard springs for the
past several hours as you can see in
these pictures they've been conducting
far researchers in car boots checking
vehicle registrations cars and buses
alike but in the last half an hour what
we understand is they've actually been
dismantled exactly why that hasn't been
confirmed hopefully good news we're also
not sure yet who these people are
connected with whether it's a
repatriation flight or those aboriginal
community members who have been staying
here following the catherine cluster
divina what we do know is that this is
definitely going to bring this gold
standard facility under intense scrutiny
on sunday we had a man escape and found
on darwin's party precinct and his
latest situation is only going to put us
under the microscope further
so we're going to get all right forgive
my accent we're going to get all the
cops out there and they're going to
bring him back and drag him back to the
detention camp where everybody is being
held because of the virus all right back
to you how's the weather yeah yeah i
watching this clip
i
did not believe it was serious news i
thought it had to be the onion or
babylon bee or a satirical outlet
how the hell did we get here
how did we get to covet detention camps
in a western allegedly civilized nation
like australia how did we get here
a lot of people beyond the covid camps
beyond that specific issue
want to get to the broader political
issue
a lot of people thought this kind of
thing could never happen oh come on
don't worry about it
a lot of people thought that all the
kooky stuff that was going on on college
campuses in in recent years oh that'll
never get out into the real world it
can't happen
those snowflakes they'll get into the
real world and then they'll straighten
out what happened the real world
bent down to the snowflakes
oh that'll stop worrying you conspiracy
theorists
there won't be covid detention camps
there there actually are right now in
australia
and then there are huge
police chases trying to track down
people who escaped the kovit camp
the problem
here for conservatives is a failure
of political imagination
it's actually a failure of imagination
and conservatives are especially guilty
of this because conservatives kind of
like the way things are and we're kind
of more normal and we're a little more
grounded and so we just think oh it's
fine
they're never going to redefine marriage
they're oh that'll never happen they're
never going to
redefine sex itself
that'll never happen
they'll never lock down the world for
two years over the woofloo that'll never
happen
they'll never have coveted camps
in a western asia that'll never it'll
it'll happen it can happen it actually
can happen guys
and and this is actually a lesson that i
think conservatives can learn
sometimes when the more
eccentric thinkers on the right
the the thinker is a little more outside
of the mainstream i'm thinking of people
like patrick dineen or adrian vermeuel
or the integralists or the i don't know
the people who maybe you haven't even
heard of these guys but they're writing
in a
a little more fringy way for the
mainstream right-wing thought
we think that can never happen that we
need to we need to lower our
expectations we need to make a deal with
the left we need to we need to concede a
lot of things to the left we need to
concede
on all of these cultural issues
actually maybe the fringier guys are
more correct maybe the fringier guys
have a have a saner view
of the boundaries of politics maybe
actually our
our modest political aims in the
mainstream right have been our downfall
maybe we need to
think more
imaginatively and maybe we need to move
that over to the window a little bit
more where we're just going to keep
losing and losing
and losing
one of the
conservative politicians right now who
is doing a great job of using his
imagination and thinking outside of the
mainstream
governor ron desantis
who is i assume he's seen the news
reports out of australia and he's
looking
at
a lot of the measures that not just the
government but the corporations and big
tech and the media are pushing an
american he's saying no
we won't let them do it
let me just say in florida
we will not let them lock you down
we will not let them take your jobs we
will not let them harm your businesses
we will not let them close your schools
the definition of insanity is doing the
same thing over and over again and
protect and expecting a different result
the lockdowns didn't stop covid force
masking they said last year would end
the pandemic if 80 wore mass many more
than that were wearing mass and it
hasn't worked they said you could get
covet off off surfaces which isn't true
they've not been honest about the
origins of the virus and they haven't
been forthright about natural immunity
and we're not going to let them do it
this is conservative
and all the hoops that you're seeing the
squishes jump through on the right to
say no but we can't we can't reign in
amazon no we can't rein in google there
google's a private company build your
own google no we can't tell companies
that they can't force everyone to take
the fauciachi experimental drug
those guys
are wrong and they have a failure of
imagination or a failure of intellect or
just a failure of courage but what
desantis is doing here is right
handful of politicians on the right who
are doing this desantis at the governor
level ted cruz i don't just say it
because he's a friend of mine he's doing
a great job josh hawley also both of
them at the senate level other people as
well
donald trump did a pretty strong job on
this maybe not so much on covid but on a
lot of other issues he did that from the
presidential level
you got to just
stand up
and
take on reality as it is conservatives
for a long time said that the left
didn't really care about reality you
know there's the left says who cares if
it works in practice does it work in
theory that's why all their policies
kept failing but we conservatives were
grounded in reality well how about we
apply that to trade how about we apply
that to our manufacturing policy how
about we apply that to
our regulation of big tech and the media
and
private corporations if the point here
is we don't think americans should be
forced to take the fouchy algae for the
virus that doesn't pose a particularly
grave threat to most of them then why
are we okay if nike forces them to do it
or ge
or coca-cola or why are we okay with
that
we're okay with people being treaded on
as long as it's not big government give
me a break
desantis and some other people have it
right here
this covett issue
is a big one and the political
realignment that's taken place around it
it actually might give us a new senator
from pennsylvania who you may have heard
of before
his name is dr oz i invented a heart
valve that saves thousands of lives
then i started a tv show to advocate for
you taking control of your health
and took on the medical establishment to
argue against costly drugs and
skyrocketing medical bills
but kovit has shown us that our system
is broken we lost too many lives too
many jobs and too many opportunities
because washington got it wrong
so dr oz may soon be senator dr oz
not unprecedented by the way talk about
a failure of imagination a lot of people
are laughing at this saying this could
never happen come on some tv star a
doctor guy that could never happen
have you ever heard of donald trump
tv star
guy could never become a prominent
politician you ever hear of ronald
reagan you ever hear of sonny bono you
ever hear of jesse ventura you ever hear
about al franken
yeah of course they can of course they
can this could never it could never be
trump it could never be reagan it could
never be yes it could dr oz could be a
senator
and he's running on a pretty convincing
campaign here because people are upset
about the coveted lockdowns and and
they're going stir crazy as rightly they
should
dr oz's platform by the way he went on
sean hannity's show his platform is just
a very basic
kind of
2000s right-wing platform
cut taxes
reduced regulation
you know it's there's nothing
particularly shocking or new about his
platform
but he's running on i'm a doctor the
medical industry sucks they've really
messed with you for the past the public
health officials have really ruined your
life the last couple of years and so i'm
running and i wouldn't be surprised
if he won
speaking of running and winning
stacey abrams
the
alleged current governor of georgia
she's not she lost that race but she
pretends to be the governor of georgia
and most democrats go along with her and
pretend that she's the governor of
georgia and that she won her georgia
race
she is running for governor
again
take a listen
you see i'm here to tell you that just
because you win doesn't mean you're one
we've got folks who are ready to take
back what they think is theirs but they
are not entitled to our progress
they are not entitled to our justice
they are not entitled to our votes
but either we use them or we lose them
i come from a state where i was not
entitled to become the governor
but as an american citizen and the
citizen of georgia i'm gonna fight for
every person who has the right to vote
to be able to cast that vote that was
just a couple months ago when stacey
abrams was campaigning in virginia for
terry mcauliffe who also lost
and stacey abrams was claiming then
that
the election was stolen in georgia
stacey abrams according to the logic of
the left is a threat to democracy and an
insurrectionist who needs to be shut out
of public life right uh no actually they
just go along with it terry mcauliffe
during that race was denying the results
of the 2000 presidential election that's
totally fine it's only when the right
wing raises questions about elections
then there are threats to the country so
stacey abrams has just announced she's
running for governor again and of course
she is and the lesson we got to take
from this is
persistence
persistence
the left is really good at this
when they win
they push further
no sooner had the left redefined
marriage for the first time ever
at this kind of radical level no sooner
had they done that then they moved on
and redefined sex sex itself
right this they keep proving the
conservative slippery slow argument
right and they don't care they just keep
pushing they take their victories and
they push further they take their losses
and they deny their losses and push
further they never stop and that's the
lesson goes right back to roe versus
wade that's the lesson for the right the
one issue that we've come close to
winning on and we might still win on is
pro-life since roe vs wade we have
pushed hard and hard and hard for 50
years
and gardened a lot of support and really
moved the needle in the pro-life
direction
now we might actually overrule roe vs
wade and and the lesson there too by the
way is once we do it if we can do it god
willing
push even further don't stop it's not
the end it's only the beginning
now
the daily wire has been hard at work
keeping their promise of bringing you
tons of content that you won't get
anywhere else
we are very excited to share one of our
highly anticipated trailers with you
the trailer features our first original
production
we released a movie last year called run
hide fight but we didn't make that movie
we acquired that movie
when hollywood didn't want to distribute
it because it wasn't politically correct
but we didn't we didn't actually produce
it this one we produced it's called shut
in it'll be available to stream in early
2022.
the film follows the story of a young
mother who is barricaded inside a closet
by her violent ex-husband
i haven't even seen the trailer yet
here it is laney
[Applause]
where have you been
going away
i'm gonna take off tonight so the kids
can sleep most of the way
[Music]
well i'm mostly done i just need to
finish cleaning out the pantry
oh
[Music]
right
please let me out please
lady
[Music]
your daughter she's very pretty don't
you touch my kids
rob
owes me money there's money there's a
lot of money there's thousands of
dollars in the pantry have it
all please come on i'm scared
that looks good
[Applause]
that not that i'm saying i didn't think
it would be good i did know it would be
there's a lot of talent the daily wire
but still when conservatives
have made movies sometimes look some
conservative movies have been terrific
and some have been a little
schmaltzy a little saccharine you know a
little kitschy and sentimental
uh not that that
that no that
that looks pretty pretty real and gritty
i can't wait to watch it can't wait to
watch the whole movie make sure you go
like and share the trailer on youtube
your support makes all the difference
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show roe vs
wade may be on the chopping block after
oral arguments at the supreme court and
joe biden's team prepares for more
coveted authoritarianism that's today on
the bench bureau show give it a listen